back then it was like um it was bad like  it was looked down upon if you had more  than a certain amount of sex partners  and you can even think of this  anecdotally like if I start telling my  mom about that if I start telling my mom  about the body counts like of girls  nowadays she's disgusted she's like what  on Earth is going on I told my grandma I  tell I tell my girl but that's like a  relevant to the conversation I tell my I  tell my grandma about like the body  counts nowadays she's like what is going  on in these streets and we could just  say like anecdotally and me when I hear  like my little sister with the stories  that they tell me I'm like what on Earth